ambiance comédie musicale à broadway
ici les artistes ont choisi de se donner
rendez vous dans cette avenue mythique
pour célébrer un anniversaire dont il se
serait bien passé déjà un an que les
producteurs de la plus célèbre des
artères musicale au monde ont été
contraints de fermer leurs portes les
taillant interdit tout rassemblement de
500 personnes ou plus à new york new
york vit grâce au tourisme est
l'attraction préférée des touristes
c'est broadway
nous rapportons des milliards de dollars
à cette industrie broadway l'oxygène de
new york
alors ça va nous prendre du temps mais
regardez c'est déjà pas mal
pas si mal pour une ville qui ne dort
jamais mais qui a dû faire une sieste
qui s'éternise et qui inquiète les
artistes du monde du spectacle vivant
qui s'alarment du risque de ne pas
parvenir malgré la reprise à redresser
la barre d'une économie culturelle en
berne depuis la crise sanitaire
actuellement les travailleurs du secteur
artistique sont en souffrance
ils ont besoin de financement et de
soutien pour se reconstruire et embellir
à nouveau nos scènes
je suis si heureuse d'être ici pour
soutenir ses incroyables institutions
cambronne week-ends qui donne aux
artistes la possibilité de faire ce
qu'ils font le mieux c'est-à-dire guéri
guérir et remplir la ville de new york
de joie
l'annoncé d'un feu vert probable pour la
mi avril sous réserve d'une baisse
continue du nombre de cas de covile 19
semble redonner le sourire à tous prévus
avec une capacité limitée 33% soit cent
personnes environ par salle la
réouverture se fera avec port du masque
et distanciation sociale obligatoire
pour le retour à une audience habituelle
de grandes productions comme frozen où
le roi lion il faudra encore attendre un
peu mais la reprise est attendue malgré
tout ça fait tellement longtemps qu'on
n'a pas chanté et dansé avec nos amis
j'en ai pleuré rien que d'entendre ces
morceaux ici à times square
c'était vraiment émouvant les choses
reprennent doucement la vie redémarre
peu à peu mais je pense qu'une fois que
broadway sera de retour cela reprendra à
100% car broadway et le coeur de cette
ville et les gens en ont besoin plus que
ce que le reste du monde peut l'imaginer
il est temps on en a vraiment besoin
mais à qui sait attendre le temps ouvre
ses portes dès le 2 avril celle des
salles de théâtre et de spectacles
devraient pouvoir accueillir leurs
spectateurs
la culture américaine semble prête à
revenir à la vie